allo les réclamations envoyées à votre
service j'écoute monsieur je ne peux pas
obtenir le 42e atteint lochon la gamine
dans le tarn et moselle et blabla autre
chose quel est votre numéro 484 31 70
bon alors ne quittez pas merci alors le
42e a hâte alors la gamine abel ne
quittez pas on vous parle de paris
allait parler monsieur allô allô allô
allô allô allô
je n'entends rien alors je me retrouve
pas parler plus fort
ah non c'est toi chérie à l'eau alors je
ne comprends pas on en redemande cissé
vous chérissez mon mardi oui oui même la
fetaf talent c'est ta ta ta ta ta ta
c'est ma femme qui dit elle elle joue de
la trompette en régie la compet
et oui acétate à taratata mais non je ne
joue pas de la tempête à l'eau alors
dite loi fourre-tout jantes ou bien
c'est toi toto un oui oui oui c'est moi
c'est moi c'est tout haut alors je ne
m'en prends rien oui c'est lui c'est
tantôt on a dit donc vous mais je vous
défends de me tutoyer
non non c'est pas moi qui vous dise à
ses hôtes mari qui dit cet essai tant
qu'auto va-t-il bien mon coeur pas mal
merci et vous tu parles je manque
pratiquement marie a par deux fois trahi
c'est à voir allô allô allô totori
voiture bien mon coeur
notre coeur
non non c'est pas moi qui dis ça c'est
votre dame qui vous demande à vous oui
non oui quoi oui quand il dit qu'il va
bien avons pensé à moi mon amour
penses-tu un peu un mois mon amour je
n'ai donc pas mal de nous l'annoncer pas
moi qui dis ça c'est attaquer sa forme
de crayon jaloux je pense à toi nuit du
jour
et toi ils y pensent à moins de 8 jours
et vous un haut niveau ça nous et vous
former ses parodies pont c'est à moi oui
allô
quant à toi c'est fou ce qu'on pensait
bien les uns les autres c'est gentil ça
non à l'eau jia qui te serrer dans mes
bras
et toi à l'eau il a de nous serrer dans
nos bras et vous elle aussi est elle a
dû serrer dans ses bras dedans non je
dis est elle à 2,2 me serrer dans ses
bras enfin de nous serrer dans ses bras
palais elle à eilat
oui allô allô allô mais qu'est ce que
vous dites je dis que vous avez hâte de
nous serrer dans nos bras nuit d'enfer
que vous chantez là qu'est ce que vous
racontez et et du temps écoutez moi j'en
ai marre
j'attends et vacances avec impatience et
je voudrais partir en bateau
mais qu'est ce que vous dites d'un petit
bateau n'avait pas ce que je faisais
juge et flic et j'ai un petit bateau
leurs pendants les abondants mais je me
fiche pas mal que vous ayez un petit
bateau elle dit qu'elle se fiche pas mal
de mon petit bateau mais qu'est ce que
vous me choper la route dit il
qu'est-ce que vous chantez je ne chante
pas flanché bien vous chantez pas danser
votre mari qui me dis qu'est ce que vous
chantez à parce que shoppers expliqué
que pendant les vacances j'ai rival mais
vous me raser avec votre petit bateau à
l'eau alors que tout montant plus
maintenant je te dis son film au courant
que les joyaux qui n'est guère en
l'attendant mais tous les trois ils
égaient très bien pour ça tellement tous
les deux enfin c'est gentil ça quand
est-ce qu'on pourrait voir quartier dit
elle dit qu'elle aimerait bien que nous
soyons tous les deux et je vous donnerai
un conseil je crois qu'elle veut plus de
vous un c'est pas possible
on a compris les camions sénat où
traînent niño maintenant ans
et maintenant que vous êtes une
andouille des landes où c'est vous et
c'est pas moi leur douce et vous c'est
dit c'est pas fait de ce pôle et de si
loin
prostrés t d'andouille à la piscine
qu'est la piscine et maintenant ils vous
traitent d'imbécile voulez tout de même
pas vous allez laisser insulter comme ça
t'en vas y renonce se raccroche je vous
dis une chose
ouais je ne plaindrai l'admiration ouais
ben ali a du culot celui-là and services
aux gens c'est vrai après dans les ptt
on dit qu'on s'énerve